many people have been calling me texting
me and emailing me over the past week
they want to understand what events have
transpired how we got here and what this
means for Bitcoin and the broader
ecosystem in the coming years rather
than continue to have these
conversations in private I thought it
would make sense to just share My Views
publicly with each of you simply I am
disappointed and I am mad I'm
disappointed in the teams that didn't
disclose the proper risk to users the
teams that misled me in private and the
teams that appeared to have made bad
decision after bad decision and put
their users at risk I'm also incredibly
mad I'm mad because some of these teams
decisions have now put individual users
at risk and they also have erased years
of progress that came from the hard work
of many great entrepreneurs and
Educators before them as many of you
know I'm an optimistic guy I believe
that technology is a positive force in
the world I believe that technology can
solve many of societal issues and it
also can unlock economic positive impact
for billions of people that were
previously at a disadvantage
on top of that I also tend to just speak
my mind if I like something I say it if
I think something is [ __ ] I say that
too my greatest strength and my greatest
weakness is that I say what I'm thinking
but there is no amount of optimism or
authenticity that can cover up what we
are facing right now
there are teams that have made grave
mistakes they have put the industry end
users at risk and now we are going to
have to sift through all of these
problems but there is no amount of
optimism or authenticity that can cover
up what we're facing there are teams
that took much more risk than was
publicly disclosed and now the average
user is facing the consequences this is
not acceptable in fact I think it's
complete [ __ ] and I feel compelled
to call it out but the worst part is
that I allowed some of these companies
to promote themselves on the platforms
that I own that was my mistake and I own
it even though I met with the teams I
questioned them on their products and
their processes and I asked to be kept
abreast of the current status of their
companies it now appears that the risk
that they were taking and the current
status of these companies was much worse
than I was led to believe now I was not
the only person that was fooled here
there were some of the best investors in
the world and millions of retail
investors that also were duped as well
that doesn't make it right and it is
unclear whether this was due to malice
or negligence but either way it is wrong
to those of you that use certain
products and are stuck in limbo I want
you to know this
I read the news just like everyone else
I had the same information that you had
I also had the same opportunity over the
past week to take my assets off of these
platforms and I chose not to do that
because that's not how I roll I'll go
down with the ship my assets aren't
coming off the platforms until the
problems are fixed and that means I have
a lot to lose but that is exactly how it
should be the second thing that I'd like
you to know is that we're going to be
making changes to the content platforms
that I own starting January 1st 2023 you
will no longer see me extend my name or
reputation for companies that I do not
own it doesn't matter what a founder or
an organization tells me we've been
burnt too many times and there is no
risk worth taking as I stated in the
beginning of this video I am
disappointed and I am Matt I've been a
public proponent of Bitcoin and these
Technologies for years now I believe in
the future of Bitcoin and I have
material skin the game but enough is
enough someone has to say that this is
[ __ ] and call it out it's a really
weird feeling to believe so deeply in
Bitcoin but have so many questions about
the various companies in the industry
everything from this moment forward will
have to be earned companies will have to
do the hard work to earn the right to
serve customers
Founders will have to do the work to
earn the right to get the world's best
talent to come help them build their
dream and investors will have to do the
hard work to earn the trust of LPS to
invest their Capital into this industry
but finally my message to each of you is
don't trust verify I have been reminded
of this lesson multiple times this year
there's a lot of chaos and uncertainty
right now and we must remember why we
are here but once the dust settles I
hope that many of you stick around to
help build the better future that we all
envision until then I wish nothing but
the best for each of you and I'll talk
to you soon